huyen de la pobreza y el hambre pero al
alcanzar la frontera con eeuu las
expectativas de los migrantes en busca
de una vida mejor no se cumplen
alentados por las políticas progresistas
del presidente yo bailé en los
desplazados se topan con la realidad más
de 100.000 detenciones o expulsiones en
la frontera mexicana sólo en febrero
nosotros nos cruzaron por la frontera de
reynosa cuando llegamos ahí pues nos
tomaron
y después no ingresaron mañana cuarto
donde están todos ya y jamás nunca nos
preguntaron nada
a dónde íbamos quién nos recibía y a
otras que estaban allí se vayan a
madrugada nos sacan y nos suben a un bus
luego nos llevan al aeropuerto y nos
suben a un avión y nos tiraron a carpas
atrás y ya de ahí el paso
de maquinar acá al puente de quads
especialmente el flujo de niños que
viajan sólo se ha disparado ellos son
los únicos en los que no expulsan del
país como bailén prometió a su llegada a
los menores son sometidos a exámenes
médicos hasta que encuentran acogida
aunque muchos tienen familiares en eeuu
la crisis ha obligado al demócrata a
desplegar a la agencia federal de manejo
de emergencias para atender a los niños
son cerca de 4000 los que se encuentran
en las oficinas de aduanas cuando llegan
los grupos casi la mitad o hasta la
mitad son los niños y estamos hablando
de
en líneas de 86 años hacia abajo niños y
niñas que vienen acompañados desde luego
con sus padres o algunos de sus padres
la situación de los migrantes amenaza
con empañar una de las principales
promesas de campaña de vaivén aplicar
una política migratoria más progresista